Today, we're learning English
with one of my favorite Pixar movies,
Finding Dory, Dory,
who is voiced by the very talented
Ellen DeGeneres, suffers from memory loss
every ten seconds or so.
But the one thing she remembers
clearly is that she was separated
from her parents as a child and decides
to go on an epic adventure to find them.
But before we dive into the movie,
if this is your first time joining us,
welcome. Each week
we help millions of learners
like you understand fast speaking English
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without needing subtitles.
So join our global community now.
Simply hit the subscribe button
and the bell down below
so you never miss out on
any of our new lessons, just like Min,
who says their confidence to speak English
has improved since watching our lessons.
Do you want to understand native speakers
of all ages and in any situation?
Well, we'll help you understand
and speak English
more confidently and naturally
with our free 3-part masterclass.
Simply sign up by clicking up here
or down in the description below.
If you enjoyed this lesson,
I definitely recommend
you continue your learning
by checking out this lesson next.